[Musique]
de New York la mise en scène du
spectaculaire de loan Green est signé
François Girard
la musique et les dirigée par un autre
québécois Yannick nez Seguin si c'est
parce qu'on est québécois mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on a la même idée par
rapport à la vision du Wagner puis on a
la même façon de travailler avec les
gens du coeur de distribution de
l'orchestre on se retient pour pas se
faire des high five devant l'orchestre
amicale par la même langue on est deux
Québécois donc on se retrouve dans la
loge c'est ça qui est un canal de
communication qui est qui facilité du
fait qu'on vient de la même place
[Musique]
est un chef-d'œuvre de Richard Wagner
créé en 1850 dans cette opéra romantique
un chevalier mystique veut à tout prix
garder l'anonymat après avoir sauvé la
duchesse Elsa
[Musique]
ce spectacle de près de 5h est grandiose
avec ses trois quarts il réunit 275
artistes sur scène en incluant
l'orchestre puis il y a des douze
trompettes or scène D1 orchestre complet
derrière la scène certains moments un
orgue et on dirait que moi plus de monde
mieux je suis le maître c'est une énorme
machine c'est la machine de théâtre que
j'ai pu voir
mais c'est une machine qui répond si on
pèse sur les sur les bons Python
[Applaudissements]
avant New York ce loan green avait été
présenté il y a un an presque jour pour
jour à Moscou au Théâtre Bolchoï le jour
de l'invasion on était au volcher avec
avec la première de cette opéra-là russe
ukrainien qui ont vécu ça en juin le
soir de la première en juin
mais dans la main il y avait ça dans le
toile de fond j'ai des souvenirs qui qui
marque et puis même aujourd'hui je
repense à ça je repense à ce qui s'est
passé un an
installer à New York pour 5 mois
François Girard présentera en mars son
adaptation du fusil de chasse avec la
légende de la danse Michael barrychnikov
il sera de retour au mètre avec Yannick
Seguin pour la reprise du vaisseau
fantôme dès le 30 mai je sens ici quand
il faut être propre une expression
anglaise désolé mais faut être hâte de
top over game fait trop au mieux au
meilleur de notre force de nos capacités
pour même pour survivre ici moi je me
lance pas le génie de Wagner continue de
me fasciner encore aujourd'hui j'entends
des choses pour la première fois
l'opéra loan green en version Yannick
tizéguin et François Girard sera
présenté derrière moi au métropole
jusqu'au premier avril au Canada on
pourra voir cette production
spectaculaire dans certains cinémas à
compter du 18 mars
[Musique]
ici oui